thank you morning KSA very chaotic and
violent episode this that unfolded on
the streets of Nottingham in the early
hours of this morning and for much of
this morning there's a lot of confusion
as to precisely what had happened people
were just seeing these large cordons
that had sprung up in different
locations around the city you can see
the trams behind us all ground to a halt
as the police moved in to secure the
scenes around these instances it's
probably quite a good idea to recap on
the chain of events for anyone who's
just joining us this morning the police
confirmed in the last hour that a 31
year old man has been arrested on
suspicion of murder after three people
were killed in the city they were called
to ilkeston Road at 4am this morning
where two people were found dead in the
street and then officers were called to
another incident in Milton streets where
a van had attempted to run over three
people and those three people we don't
know where they are connected at all to
the suspects but they are currently
being treated in hospital and a man has
also been found at another location in
Nottingham we're right in the city
center just opposite the uh Main theater
here very busy part of the city and of
course a lot of concern from people as
to what on Earth has led to this burst
of police activity through the course of
the morning and now Nottinghamshire
police able to share the initial details
of this incident that very sadly three
people have lost their lives and that 31
year old man is now being held in
custody and of course the questioning of
him will be crucial to try to understand
what on Earth happened in this city in
the early hours of this morning but of
course it has led to a lot of distress a
lot of confusion and a lot of shock that
that violent chain of events could have
unfolded we understand from witnesses
that that suspect was arrested at
gunpoint by armed police officers in one
part of the city in the early hours and
that white van will also be crucial to
the police investigation was that a van
that belonged to the suspect why was he
seemingly from what the police have said
deliberately targeting
pedestrians on the road those three
people are still being treated in
hospital but a further three people are
dead and the police's main suspect is
now in custody and they have said that
this is an horrific and tragic instance
which has claimed the lives of three
people this from Chief Constable Kate
manell she says we believe these three
incidents are all linked and we have a
man in custody the investigation is at
its early stages and a team of
detectives is working to establish
exactly what has happened we asked the
public to be patient while inquiries
continue and at this time a number of
roads in the city will remain closed as
this investigation progresses and as you
can see behind us this is one of the
busiest parts of Nottingham right
outside the theater the tram lines
running past it all of it come to a
whole people now picking their way
around the cordons here in the middle of
Nottingham trying to digest the news
that has come from the police force that
this man now is in custody
it seems that the police are confident
that the incidents are over and under
control but of course a tragic toll
three people losing their lives in the
early hours of this morning in
Nottingham three others in hospital and
one man in custody undergoing police
questioning